35 years ago a report released by the
Reagan administration blamed a rising
tide of mediocrity on the American
education system since then the
conversation on how to improve our
classrooms has continued one acclaimed
school network says rigorous standards
and ingenuity are why its students
ranked among the top in the world
Danielle Nottingham has the story it's
rare to see high schoolers show this
much enthusiasm about anything
especially a math problem Riley
Deepti and Ashutosh come on down but
this isn't your average high school
this is basis independent Silicon Valley
a $28,000 a year private school a
stone's throw from some of the world's
leading tech companies erase the board's
pleas they do this in the real price is
right they over bid all the time in fact
I was a part of two over bids in a row
AP calculus teacher Billy Thomas is a
life long prices right ban
and one time contestant and start again
lower than 700 550 because this is the
prices right and because we like to have
fun he plays game show host to teach
complex math to students as young as 12
I can hand out a review packet and we
can go through it and sometimes we do do
that
but the game show sort of gives them
this idea of the pressure of the test
and more so than that it gives them the
chance to just realize that learning can
be fun students here are required to
take at least 7 advanced placement
courses beginning as early as 8 grade
they must take 6 AP tests to graduate
but some take as many as 20
were you ever skeptical that the kids at
this level would be able to take these
lessons and really know this material
when I first started I thought they were
kind of crazy I mean I really did I was
like you can't teach an eighth grader or
a seventh grader to do AP calculus and
what I discovered was if you put kids up
to a challenge you will be surprised how
high they can go and how much they can
meet that challenge for economist dr.
Michael and Olga block the average
American school was not challenging
enough for their daughter that's why
they opened a charter school in 1998
focused on serious subject training that
first basis location in Tucson Arizona
has grown to a chain of 31 Charter and
private schools basis is so successful
it captured the top 5 spots on the US
News and World Report's best high
schools list so when you do your windows
your building is going to be going up
and down up and down up and down here
teachers are experts in their subjects
but not necessarily licensed educators
kindergartners learn Mandarin and
engineering and eighth-graders
experiment in chemistry under the
supervision of a teacher with a PhD this
is an old IBM facility that we we
gossiped it we retrofitted it and send
it into the school Toby Walker is head
of schools at basis independent Silicon
Valley how do the students here compared
to students from around the world so we
do rank our students international
performance and our students here at
this school routinely outperforming the
highest performing students in the
highest performing regions of the world
in math reading and science one of those
students is 9th grader anna subhana how
much homework do you have
I think about like three hours a night
which sounds like a lot but that's like
the average and I'm taking two ATP's and
you feel like you still have time to be
a teenager yeah yeah I do like three
clubs and I do 12 hours of dance a week
and I volunteer three hours on weekends
I have time to do like what I want to do
Anna's mom Sri Vidya Gopalan is the
director of engineering at a cyber
security company is this the school to
send your children to in Silicon Valley
I have two kids my first kid graduated
out of Asus my second one is going to
bases if I had a third that kid would go
to bases too for sure although the focus
here is on STEM education pens and
pencils are preferred and cell phones
banned bases also refuses to rank
students there are no class
valedictorians I think that for us it's
important that in the classroom students
can be focused on engaging with the
material getting to know their teachers
and really setting expectations for
themselves and surpassing them rather
than competing with their peers what
would you say to people who would say
that the curriculum here is too
difficult it's too challenging or
demanding and it may stress students or
maybe give them some kind of anxiety
quite honestly I would say to them come
and talk to our students spend spent
time in the building we really focus on
making sure that these students are
supported that as they engage with what
is a very rigorous curriculum they get
the the safety net that they need
the curriculum is why a basis charter
school teacher said she filed a
complaint in 2014 with the US Department
of Education office for civil rights
she said the school told her it did not
modify its curriculum for students with
disabilities basis says it takes very
seriously the obligation to serve all
student populations including students
with disabilities and accepted a
voluntary resolution with a policy
review and the opportunity for
additional training you're going to tell
me what the derivative is in each one of
these slots so back in Silicon Valley
math teacher Billy Thomas says no matter
how challenging the subject with the
right support any child can succeed you
can't do that in most schools across the
country and to be a part of that to be a
part of educating kids at this high
level I really can't imagine something
more fulfilling yes for CBS this morning
Saturday Danielle Nottingham San Jose
California three hours of homework a
night that seems like a lot haven't done
was doing what she said she was doing
twelve hours of dance yeah those are
high achieving kids the challenge and
the fun part though I even remember when
a teacher would do that a jeopardy game
to make it more interesting yes and to
remember those do you do